okay we did an operation blind date days
okay so let's do this I'm worried my
sucking headphones again because the
pizza man came and I ate the pizza sound
like I had nothing more - let's have fun
yeah yeah yeah skyranger my ass began it
the human VIP working in collaboration
with Advent is being operation lion egg
des the resistance is asked that we step
in and neutralize the target we'll need
to secure the area and destroy the enemy
forces providing security bring the
package home alive if possible but don't
take any chances
how do you bring him home alive
come on come on hurry up now that's 15
for a second ah bet yeah here we go
there we go I'm taking now
Shanta
menace 1/5 target location confirmed
move to engage eliminate all hostile
contacts have you capture them
no knows how in the capture ok got if I
can get up there hey were you
they were you they were you I'm not
right the [ __ ] are these [ __ ]
in the morning son hmm
hey were you they were you
they were you moving out
okay bet my mouth mouth mouth haze alien
have no idea what's come on father
okay so how do I take this batch yeah
I'm alright get out there [ __ ]
ah
okay absolutely we're skate but let's
see what happens you're with us
one way or another target identity
confirmed
menace one five remember we're here to
capture the VIP if possible knock them
out and bring them in okay
our gremlins can attempts to access the
advent network from here we might be
able to hack their systems and get an
advantage but be careful if they detect
us things will only get worse okay
getting it done I'm shrink getting it
done
ah [ __ ]
Jobeth cow
okay this is where a bar touch
that's just bet okay okay so past hmm if
I move okay
on it talking bird down there are just
comes I'm on the move
caca hack hack what not thank you
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] it oh we got him taken care
off save this can go pretty good
yeah just cracked especially grenade oh
we [ __ ] totally throwing it at them I
agree what you doing now
okay okay
okay come on just kill oh we got them
should be dead right yeah hit the sable
okay okay bench get the [ __ ] over here
golden-colored on the move
groaning out okay
I would like to subdue that [ __ ] now
talking Rucker okay sup death holy [ __ ]
confirmed target package in custody
okay copy that ya betch cow
moving out shut
got something new yeah good copy
moving on target well do these guys got
to get the [ __ ] out of here
look Lana called in some writing [ __ ] oh
that's fine menace one five we're
picking up an enemy transport inbound on
your current position carry unit
okay let's go chance to go
let's go pick up your feet on the move
get the [ __ ] out come on come on [ __ ]
come on
hack now should do eight burn us all now
get the [ __ ] out of here
make merry move hey back double time
moving on target location
not yet [ __ ] okay I don't think they can
shoot on the turn can I already there
wait how the [ __ ] is you get in there
got it moving
I have the [ __ ] out of here
this [ __ ] has to evac for sure I'm gone
this [ __ ] should do a protocol on em
okay that's [ __ ] you back just in
time
Oh what the [ __ ]
oh yeah then overwatch I'm gonna Roger
that come on [ __ ]
a vac VIP secure and in position for Eva
well what a smooth [ __ ] mission
minutes one five the target is down
repeat we've lost the package status
confirmed mission accomplished
perfect [ __ ] Bravo
[ __ ] Bravo that's how you do it you
get pizza and you do this okay Barry -
take that thank ya